good morning members good morning
members of the public
you're very welcome this morning gotta
follow gender here today so May first
our first of all that our asked the
officer to read out the health and
safety regulations yes good morning
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room down the corridor cold water is
also available in the breakout area if
the fire alarm should sound we don't
expect a fire drill today please leave
the meeting follow the fire exit signs
and meet on the Ipswich Town Football
Club training pitch and remain there
until you are told it is safe to return
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn into silence
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meetin will be broadcast live to
the Internet and capable of repeated
feelin the whole of the meetin will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempted items if you
make a representation to the meeting you
will be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcast and and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and press may film record
photographed or broadcast this meetin
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded Baber district council
our first recording this need any member
of the public who attends the meetin and
objects the bein film should have
opposed the committee Clark there's
nobody wish to make any representations
no as far as I'm aware and no one has
indicated that they were filming or that
they do not want to be filmed in
accordance with the council's plan and
charter members of the public are not
permitted to communicate were the
furball er in writin with members of the
committee during the course of the
meeting including any adjournments if a
member of the committee is approached by
a member of the public then they must
immediately draw it to my attention and
also to the attention to legal affairs
are present if a member of the public
attempts to communicate with a member of
the committee then they may be asked to
leave the meet and finally can members
officers and any public speakers ensure
that you press the microphone for
speakin and turn off when you have
finished and please keep as close to it
as possible and try not to hold your
papers over like that because that will
make the distorted thank you
all right substitutes and apologies yes
we have received an apologies from
councillor sac Norman and councillor sue
Aires councillor Margaret Mary is
substituting for councillor errors thank
you
and we do not have a sub for cancel the
Norman
because I've got down Mary McLain she
hasn't a double hidden context - we had
a big contact thank you so Kent we've
also received an apology councillor
Hinton it was rather late but we've
received a punishment can st. and
counselor maybe Thank You chairman I am
counsel at Margaret Mary and I am
substituting for counselor suit Ayres
who is currently on vacation
thank you very much and because there is
a application in your ward later your
remaining a member of the committee
throughout the whole morning
correct mr. chairman thank you yes I
declare that I am the count
the ward member for Lebanon but I intend
to stay on the Planning Committee and
not speak as the ward member thank you
thank you
declarations of interest we're just
right before we before we leader know
Derrick Davis you see not substituted
for John Ensign now I'm sorry and
councillor Hinton I don't think he'd
informed the officers and by the time
they got to hear of it it was past the
deadline which is one o'clock yesterday
lunchtime and members it is important
that
we do have to get the names in as we
found out at the last meet and bow at
one o'clock but can I ask if you Derek
Davis's taking the trouble to read all
the papers and turn up and our limited
numbers wouldn't it be beneficial it
might be beneficial
I might even support it but I don't
think we can bend the rules at all
counsellor and possibly further if you
counsel Busbee or you particular want me
to write green basically yeah I'd like
to know why he can't do well I mean we
have a rule in the Constitution and
they're planning the planning charter
and I think if we didn't follow it
without a very exceptionally good reason
we even if we did have someone looking
like an exactly good reason there would
be an argument that we had breached our
own internal rules and that would cast
some doubt over the legality of
decisions made hence the Busbee he was
here at the last meeting your dough yeah
we had counselor Mick Fraser present who
would actually contacted them in the
about 17 minutes past 3:00 I think it
was which was too late but he also had a
planning application coming up so he
actually was in the room and set there
but he was still not allowed to take
part only on that planning application
so we've got one rule we're already set
apply to all of them thank you
we're on these aren't
declarations of interest
Cancellara Thank You mr. chairman um I
just like to so have an on procuring
interest I just like to go to our
solicitor for for advice but it's on
item DC not DC 19 stroke 203 614 a
student my wife actually is a cabinet
member for housing that matters but I'll
check with the legal then what will
counselor Osborn just spoke to me and we
agonize the bit about whether to even
mentioned it's the law nowadays over
knowledge is husbands and wives and
partners are independent of each other
but I think an average remember the
public might think well if counselor
Osborn happens to be married to the
cabinet member who's has some
involvement as politically as for the
service area it is something that should
for the sake of comfort be declared so
that that's been done thank you very
much if you're happy then we'll be happy
also item three to turn the minutes held
on the 6th of November they've all been
circulated and you've seen them can I
accept them as a true record cancel that
I was born seconded by Councillor
Barrett all those in favor please show
that's carried thank you very much I'll
sign them down
I took four to receive a notification
million petitions received yeah
site inspections do we have any site
inspections and killed members do have
any site inspections you wish to request
no good that means then that site
inspection day next Wednesday the 27th
you have the day off again you can all
go Christmas shopping and perhaps take
out your our house and they can enjoy it
oh okay thank you very much I'll hold
you to that councillor Busby after a
little chat this morning I have come to
the conclusion that you do have a heart
right we'll we'll move on to item number
six plan and applications for
determination by the committee right
we've got them in front of you
the first one is 6a on page nine the
case of afar is leaving stone
overdue sleeve lovely thank you chair
good morning members and just as a bit
of housekeeping and in the late papers
members will have seen that we have
received a further response from the
council psychologist just confirming
that they're satisfied in relation to
likely impacts upon protected species
however their objection remains in
relation to priority species and ie
farmland birds so for that reason the
relevant reason for refusal at the end
of the paper still stands because whilst
we're satisfied in respected Prior and
protected species and we're still not
satisfied in respective priority species
I don't make sense right so in respect
of the item before you this is an
outline planning application some
matters being reserved with us
considering the site access is for the
erection of up to 150 dwellings use of
land for community facilities public
open space landscaping suds a vehicular
access point from Franklin Hill and
that's following demolition of an
existing bungalow and outbuildings the
location is land west of Grantham Hill
the applicant is Gladman developments
the site here is nine point three six
hectares this is not location plan just
for context members we've des obviously
the village of Brampton to the east here
adjacent Brampton peel being the main
road through leading down towards
Manningtree
and then it's switch to the north
Manningtree railway stations about two
and a half kilometers away and extend
just to the north here and obviously
east burgle to the north west is a
constraints map just to pick up here
members you've got a number of them
public rights-of-way that move around
the site and indeed abutting its western
boundary here and the built-up area
boundary follows the random hill road
and cuts through the front of the sites
so effectively as you'll note from the
papers for all intents and purposes and
the residential aspects of the
development will all be outside of will
be at abutting the settlement boundary
Branson being a hinterland village in
the core strategy
I throw the constraints map just
identifying here that the western
boundary of the site that's the Dedham
Vale area of outstanding natural beauty
and members will also know from the
papers I think on page eleven that there
is a further diagram provided which
shows the siting context adjacent to the
Dedham variable area of outstanding
natural beauty and then also to the east
and the north
you'll see the proposed extension areas
to the southern coast and Heath's
Aon B which in all likelihood is likely
to be approved and extended there is an
order which is currently with the
Secretary of State but for the purposes
of this application we've considered the
AO and visas they currently stand but in
any event the southern coast of the
piece AR and B is within proximity to
the site from its eastern boundary this
is an aerial map which to shows a little
bit more context members will recall
that earlier this year we approved
reserved matters for the Taylor Wimpey
scheme as part of the brand than the
generation site and allocation just to
the south here the other thing I think
I'd point out to members is there is
really in in officer's opinion a really
quite strong and defined sense of place
characterized by the spine road brand
thumb Hill which runs down here which
effectively sets the border between the
village and the landscape to the west
and then sort of in there in the belly
of the village so to speak to the east
you then got all of the built aspects
there and then a further red line plan
which just shows how the the site has
been has being drawn this southern
boundary is sort of arbitrary and it's
in its drawing there are no particular
landscape features that run along here
other than this this wooded area cops
just here which the red line follows
around and the access to the site
obviously off Brandon Hill is just here
following past an existing bungalow that
I'll show you in photos in a moment and
then outbuildings here that your centre
demolition
this is an access plan same access I
think the one on the right is just
slightly enlarged obviously just showing
how the site would meet Brant them Hill
and I'll run through that when we get to
the photos in a second and then this is
development framework plan so as I said
let's start this is an outline planning
application so effectively we're
considering the principle of the
development and also its access the
framework plan is is showing how the
development could be brought forward
where you have here the residential
aspects of built aspects of the scheme
here and then there's proposed to be
landscaping sort of enclosing the site
the enclosing the residential
developments with such features and
obviously a open space as well as a
woodland type buffer at the front of the
site you've also got an area of land
which has been allocated for community
purposes and as set out in the papers
just moving on their members to some
pictures and then this is another
viewing context this has a lidar
representation which shows that you do
have a site which is sort of gently
undulating and then there are a change
in levels sort of moving gradually down
towards the river there obviously the
application site being roughly in this
location public right-of-way running
across here roughly and then also along
here it was I'm tracing with the mouse
on some photos so this is from the
proposed site access looking south onto
Brandon Hill and then north and then of
the access itself this is the bungalow
that would be set the demolition to give
way to obviously make improvements for
the access itself and where the
community land is proposed to be and
just a further photo you can also pick
up some of those dilapidated buildings
there that would be set the demolition
if members were minded to approve this
application computer recommendation and
photos this is from one of the footpaths
off of Slough Road to the north of the
site just looking down and across I mean
unfortunately these pictures doesn't
quite do it justice this is a
particularly fantastic landscape and
bearing in mind all of the public
rights-of-way that do move around the
site it's clearly offers great
recreational and benefits to to members
of the public this is from one of those
public rights-of-way which runs parallel
to the northern boundary of the site
just looking south and this is slightly
enlarged you so effectively the
development would be set right in the
foreground of this picture and one thing
you can't quite pick up from here and
also in another photo in a moment that
is as you move down in a southern
southerly direction along the public
rights-of-way you can pick up the sort
of the gentle undulations in the
landscapes it leads you down to really
quite a fantastic view of the river
which of course is going to
substantially change should development
go ahead this is from sort of the
northwestern corner of the site you can
sort of just pick up generally some of
that kind of focal view there that I've
just mentioned down towards the river
you've also got Brandon Hill just here
to the left of the picture
this is from the same perspective now
but looking at Brandon Hill and the
proposed area for the site access
leading then into the site and that's
the end of the photos
so effectively members just to take it
to the end of the the paper I'll just
remind you the planning balance and
conclusion obviously decision taking
begins with a development plan its
invites an importance of planning
decisions a plan lead the MPP F which is
of course an important material
consideration reiterates that point the
circumstances of this application are
not exceptional and my mother issues
identified the development represents
discordant projection into open
countryside in the immediate setting of
the dead and Valeo and be undermining
the way that it is experienced adults
with a very clear and defined spatial
grain and within a sensitive landscape
context which offers could officers
consider to be a valued landscape with
regard to an MPP F parlance it would be
an unwelcome growth latched to the spine
of Brampton the applicant has further
failed to prove their justifiable need
for the development to have in regard to
local circumstances the application
chiefly conflicts with the ride range of
policies it offends the development plan
when taken as a whole the application is
also deficient in a number of other ways
within to the insufficient information
being provided in respective highways
archaeology drainage and ecology and the
council has set out and the papers
cannot be satisfied that the development
would be acceptable in relation to those
matters in the absence of appropriate
detail the council can demonstrate that
it has a five-year housing land supply
and taken in the round the most
important policies for the dissemination
of this application do remain up to date
the application cannot therefore benefit
from the tilted ballasts are set out in
the core strategy on the MPPs assessed
against the MPP F the application
performs no better it be contrary to the
development plan and to National
Planning Policy and there are no
material considerations are justified
apart from those policies the harm
identified significantly under monitored
emotionally outweighs the benefits on
that basis members you are invited to
refuse planning permission and for the
various reasons that are set out on page
thirty seven and eight
papers thank you thank you very much
Steven for that full and comprehensive
report it's a sight we all know off and
read and through lots of the things
we've seen before
we've no public speakers here parish
came to object to support applicant our
agent or County Council above the local
board member can slit and crawl if you
have up to five minutes which to address
the committee thank you chair and good
morning to members I'll try and keep
this brief not least because I have a
horrible cold I'm sure that might be
something believed you not the cold bit
obviously sorry I apologize it's the
cold okay this application falls into a
category of some of the more speculative
outline ones that we've seen during the
period where we were unable to
demonstrate a five year land supply now
that condition no longer exists and
we're able to give the proper weight to
our own policies I'm just going to
trundle through the main points of the
report and I know that all members know
this stuff but we sometimes forget that
the public as a whole
fine planning in general not necessarily
easy to understand heaven knows we've
all worked hard enough to trying
ourselves to grasp it but since we now
webcast and we're aiming for
transparency I thought it worth
summarizing for all those interested or
concerned who may view this now or later
and that's part of what we do summarized
you have a clear background in part to
Paris to 213 the consultation in part
three paris 14 233 shows consistent
objections from the most significant
council tease both the parish councils
consider anthem highways flood
archaeology planning policy landscape a
OMB and there are holding objections
elsewhere these largely are on the
grounds of access transports lack of
information the emerging local plan and
safety the report is very strongly
expressed in part for policy framework
paris 34 to 126 providing supporting
examples of which engaged policies are
failed and
why the principle of development under
cs2 and CS 11 is failed there are no
exceptional circumstances Paris 65 and
66 show almost complete failure of the
criteria landscape effects in Paris 68
to 88
refer not only to CS 11 CS 14 CS 15 but
multiple paragraphs of the npp F this is
undeveloped land that should remain so
for many demonstrated reasons land that
makes Suffolk what it is and should
remain a rural landscape with pockets of
development only we have room for both
the section continues to examine highway
impacts and I'm pleased to see reference
to cumulative impact that we have
perhaps not given full consideration to
in the past the rate of growth of cars
now exceeds that of population and there
are considerable local safety aspects on
Bradford Hill this sort of proposed
access point should always be subject to
close scrutiny of Archaeology flood risk
ecology and agricultural land I have
little to add there are of course
benefits attached Paris of 120 to 126
but those are no more than required by
policy and with so much else
non-compliant with policy that can only
be one decision part five the planning
balance in conclusion Paris 127 to 130
to list these and invite a refusal of
Planning Commission in passing I'd like
to add that the style and structure of
this report has been very useful not
only to me and perhaps to you but I
think to the public at large and it's
not just because I agree with the thrust
of the report it might appear
straightforward to us but we know it
takes a lot of time to distill these
matters down to a clear spirit something
very close to my heart it's not often
that members of this Planning Committee
will be presented with such a unanimous
view from community from statutory and
non-statutory Council T's from our own
qualified officers and through our own
and national policies ask members to
continue that unanimity by a decision to
resolve the recommendation to refuse for
all the reasons given a
end of the report I thank you for your
time thank you very much members any
questions to the ward member okay thank
you very much there's no questions right
members it's over to you we would like
to start the debate okay cancelados but
yeah Thank You mr. Sharon um in all the
years I've sat on planning I'm sorry
in all the years I sat on planning I've
never seen as many objections as has
been put into this case and I think
Steven Strad has done a really good job
on this one and obviously where the ward
member here emphasizing the fact of
those policies and the MPP F and I can't
I can't have any reason not to propose a
refusal for the offices of
recommendation the only one the only one
I would say is that with a large amount
of housing like this unfortunately
probably it might fall on other areas to
take up this amount of housing thank you
members who have seen the tape and paper
so I'll just remind what that exactly
when there is a paragraph relating to
this item thank you well that posed the
drive a seconder Chancellor plum do wish
to comment only to say that this matter
over in settled Thank You chair thank
you
any other comments what Chancellor
Barrett Thank You chair just wanted to
add to Adrienne's comments about
highways because I I've not actually
seen highways highways object to
proposal before
so I think that's quite significant and
I you know I think we all understand the
issues affecting the roads in that area
so I would like to add my my thoughts to
refuse all of this application thank you
very much
councillor Parker it is now just like to
add to all of the comments that are
being suggested here this morning or so
here this morning I like to see a debate
around these as a role but frankly the
reasons are so compelling and so
comprehensive that it kind of stops us
from from having that debate in many
respects so I just on a technical point
always interested to know because we you
know we do here in other cases that for
whatever reason cs2 and the need for
exceptional circumstance might be
mitigated by policy elsewhere that is
clearly not the case here I just
wouldn't mind some clarification around
why that is particularly yeah I think
the waiting to be afforded to policy
it's a matter of judgment and it can
vary on the circumstances that you've
got before you I think what you have
here is a blatant conflict with the
development plan as a whole it's not
just cs2 it's a range of other policies
and because of the breadth of issues
that you've got I mean it's going to be
very difficult to identify why there
would be exceptional circumstances here
or indeed why if there were compliance
but the other policies in the
development plan why perhaps a conflict
with cs2 would be less significant as a
result when you're bouncing up and
weighing the various considerations and
indeed the benefits of the scheme which
of course are quite significant because
this is a scheme for 150 houses it done
does bring with it a lot of social and
economic benefits but actually the the
harm here is so acute that actually by
any measure that this scheme simply not
supportable and and in you know as I say
in the concluding remarks it does no
better when scored against the MPPs so
you've effectively got nothing to
play against the policy harm that you've
got in respect to the development plan
so as I say however you cut it I think
this is this is a refusal obviously the
applicant has a right of appeal they
clearly have a number of reasons refusal
that they would need to work through I
think at its heart this is a landscape
case and I don't think they're gonna get
away from the fact that there is really
quite a significant landscape harm
particularly bearing in mind that this
is considered to be a very bad deed
landscape within the setting especially
of that dead and bone a onb and you know
it's not that there is a clearly defined
break between this site and the arrow in
B I mean they effectively merge into
into one I mean it's clearly a very
sensitive landscape and you know of
itself just planting a lot of trees
around the site I don't think it's going
to ameliorate the the very significant
visual impacts that there would be I
mean the landscape would be transformed
as a result so I think however you cut
it and there's really quite severe harm
here other applications that you might
have come coming before you in weeks or
months and to follow that may be very
you know much finer balance that needs
to be struck where the kind of the
degree of conflict for those policies
might not be so so quite a great or
significant but it's it's been across
the board no yeah I think thank you
your us to come back Oh circe much come
back to thank you I'm still not very
fulsome explanation I'll just as just as
a point to note mr. chairman I think
it's very disappointing that an
applicant that seeks to put 150 houses
on our district in our district against
policy isn't here to to represent or
explain themselves I think that's a very
poor state of affairs to just say that
miss Jenna thank you thank you it's
noted penciler Park on ok can I just be
reassured by the chief planning officer
that our five-year lens supply is robust
at this present tell you thank you the
short answer is yes
over to you then Steven aha I don't
actually know much much more to Adam in
the the recent housing lancerpoint
position statement that was published in
September it's up to date and respect to
the fact that it follows national
planning policy and guidance so we're
satisfied that it's robust in that
respect and and it reflects the most
up-to-date position of the council
obviously that's not the only route in
to identify whether the quote-unquote
tilted balance is engaged that also
relates to the dative nosov policies and
whether taken in the round they're up to
date and you know as I set out in the
papers there may be a degree of
inconsistency with Paulo between policy
cs2 and the MPP F but the rest of the
policies taken in the round that Baskar
the policies that are applicable in this
in these circumstances are absolutely up
to date so this is to be determined and
dismissed in a course with a development
plan there are no other material
considerations to indicate otherwise
thank you members have you any other
questions canceller Busby can we go back
to this the slide you can pull up slide
5 I think please
and I think that one just shows how out
of place it would be to what houses in
there you've got a very strict linear
development along the road there if you
move on to nine so I jump about you you
actually referred to this as gently
falling to the river I think you missed
the clue that it's on Grantham Hill if
you've ever tried to cycle up that hill
it is not gently in any shape or form
and if you go into the photographs
yep can I just say that they're probably
the worst photographs of fields I've
ever seen in my life
they don't do absolutely anything for
the presentation whatsoever bring back
Vincent we're busy
when we need him certainly can the point
I think the key point here is that
there's no proven need from the
applicant in any shape or form there's
no housing survey or whatever actually
in your paragraphs in your report and
paragraph 59 you talk about 144 in
Grantham in Burgos to 288 in Grantham
already
we don't actually mention the this
hapless hundreds the other side of the
river in in Lawford I think that will
impact upon the highways infrastructure
particularly the the underpass at the
bridge surely that needs to be taken
into account as well so there is nothing
going for this application thank you
very much
despite the fact that we didn't have a
bike with you to go up and down this
hill for pencil possibly your folio
goings review has any other comments
members that no I'm sorry
any other fees no canceller but may I
just sort of ask for advice on how much
weight we should give to the NEET the
need or the you know we talked about
that so the houses that are approved
currently at Brooklands is that 300 yeah
it's that demonstrating that me need has
been met is that is that what this
hinges on as ever that's a matter of
judgment
I think the point for the policy is that
it is incumbent upon the applicant to
demonstrate how their particular
proposal meets a need and I think as a
matter of common sense I think you can
see that there's got a lot going on in
that that's village and it's and it's
functional cluster and it would be for
the applicant to show why there is a
residual needs
for that that quantum of development
that's proposed and they simply haven't
done that so that is another you know
not an officer opinion conflict would be
with the policy itself and and indeed
the MPP F which requires applications to
respect local circumstances if if the
applicant is not in a position to be
able to tell us what those circumstances
are and why this application would fit
well then it fails to meet the terms of
that policy no doubt you know I'm
guessing here but I should imagine the
applicant will now go away and do a bit
of work as a prelude to an appeal but
will will have to respond to that when
it happens which is precisely what
happened with the Melford inquiry in the
summer Thank You councillor Busby I
think you been chilly powder 42 that the
emerging plan is in its very early
stages please tell me that five years
it's not taking us five years to get to
very early stages and that this thing is
almost complete you know you spheres
well I can I can give a comment from a
development management perspective which
is that at this particular stage bearing
in mind the relevant steps that a plan
has to go through before it's adopted
and this is still at the early stage is
regulation 18 preferred options as it
were kind of a a consultation based on
the direction of travel that the council
would like to go in I'm sure there are a
great number of comments that have been
received through that consultation
process it's still obviously not yet
been for examination it hasn't gone out
through its legal compliance draft
there's there's still a fair way to go
and I think whilst some of the evidence
supporting that plan that's clearly
going to be very important depending
from the circumstances I think the way
to be afforded to it as a whole is
probably quite limited but effectively I
mean it's not going to play a
deterministic role in this particular
application especially when our current
development plan is so forcefully
telling us
this is a refusal obviously we need to
be careful because I think there should
be a reason moment we have spent a lot
of time getting to this stage and I know
the the official stages of still have
got to be complete but I'd be very
surprised if so it's charge of order
okay chief against four pockets yes
Anning application all the like stage of
the John Michael plan well I think I
think I think in fairness to councilor
pulse beats it is in the papers in front
of us so I think I'm going to allow him
to make the to make those comments
councillor Busby I think it's very
dangerous that to state that it could in
in other applications come back and bite
us if I think most of us wolf will look
at this and say well if it's in this
draft local plan then that is the law D
to end up in the full local plan I can't
see applications and allocations of
sites changing much in the local plan I
I think there needs to be able to be
honest I think there needs to be a
degree of caution there I mean it's
clearly an important document and it's
an expression of preference on behalf of
the council and certainly the direction
of travel is important to note but I'm
afraid the plan remains untested and the
MPPs it's very clear that you need to be
careful with the amount of weight that
your portions or such documents as they
emerge I'm gonna ask our legal planning
expert just a comment and give us the
legal jargon just a set that's exactly
right mr. Stroud is exactly right and we
we must follow the the MPPs advice here
may be dangerous to do otherwise
thank you I moved a nun then is there
any other comments no
right we've had a recommendation to
follow the officers really sorry we've
had a proposal to move the officers
recommendation for refusal proposed by
councillor Osborne seconded by
Councillor plan all those in favor
please show to refuse it's unanimous
okay thank you very much
all right members we'll move on to page
41 and the case officer is Jack
wilkinson but unfortunately he's broken
his leg playing football I think it also
injured his shoulder before then so he's
doing quite well but I think he's a
footballer and days may be coming to a
corrupt in we've got Libby who's going
to take us through this okay Thank You
chair so this is an application for
reserved matters for the details
apparent scale layout and landscape for
the erection of 25 dwellings it should
be noticed that the principle of
development and access has already been
agreed under the outline application and
therefore only looking at a parent scale
layout lungs and landscape okay so I
think unfortunately some of the pages
haven't come out on the photos are in
there okay so just to let you know that
there is some lake papers so you'll see
that in page 15 of the application there
are further comments from 11 and parish
council following those comments we have
received a response from the applicant
who has explained a little bit more for
their reasoning for putting the
affordable housing in one single group
and they've stated that it does provide
a more attractive is it a proposition
for acquisition by register provider as
it means that the access road and car
parking spaces and can be set that would
serve the affordable properties can be
transferred in one entirety to the RP
concerned and I'll show you that on the
layout plan and also that from a
construct
delivery perspective it means that the
affordable housing can be built and
transferred in accordance with the 106
agreement which requires the eight
affordable dwellings to be provided
after the eight market Wellings
again I can show you how that might work
on the layout also we are proposing an
additional condition which is to provide
details of materials and that will
ensure that the materials for the
affordable and the market dwellings are
the same and therefore that the
development will be tenure Hynde so
sorry so to get back to this one
this just shows the site it is you can
see the helots carriage to the north and
the two roads are melted Road which
leads to Acton and just along here and
Sudbury Road here which goes leads to a
great moulding field and Sudbury and the
remainder of the village is up here to
the north again that just provides a bit
more context you can see these of Altis
after outskirts of the village and some
other suburban sort of cul-de-sac
layouts again this provides the
constraint there's only one constraint
on the site which is this TPO
hedge here which is being retained you
can also see the boundary of the
built-up area about here but the
principle of development on this site
has already been agreed aerial
photograph you can just about make out
that there are there is a line of trees
along this side here and you might just
about see the hedge here that's the TPO
hedge so this is the site layout you can
see it's a sort of a cul-de-sac
arrangement so there's a cold
here and cold saw here and then one over
here you'll also note that they're
retaining the existing tree about here
and providing a landscape buffer and
open space adjacent to it
this is the access which has previously
been approved and you'll also note that
there is proposed landscaping here this
is the TPO hedge that would be improved
and landscape buffer here between the
site and the garage there have been
concerns about the site the location of
these in relation to the garage and
you'll note from your report that the
environmental protection officers
comments however when they didn't always
monitoring the main issue was from these
two roads rather than from the garage
and they are providing a buffer so it is
considered that this arrangement would
be acceptable in relation to neighbor
immunity and the new occupiers in
relation to the garage you'll also
notice the concerns from the parish
council regarding the affordable housing
being clustered in one location so the
affordable housing are these plots here
to here free there these two and this
one here you'll note that the comment
that the agent of the applicant
mentioned in terms of ownership this is
the access drive and this is sort of the
shared parking court so this could all
be transferred to the RP which does make
it easier in management terms as they
wouldn't then have to pay a service
charge to the management company for
upkeep of this and we have had problems
in the past about affordability once you
add a service charge to affordable
dwellings as well as that that you can
see how potentially they could build a
first stage than the affordable housing
in relation to the 106 agreement and
then the third stage so it does make
phasing of the development easier
it's also you should note that this is
private housing here so it's not
physically separated from the house from
the market housing it's just in a one
cluster the general advice we receive
from a firm strategic housing is that it
should be no more than a cluster of 15
affordable dwellings in this case it's 8
so these show the street scenes this is
hey so this is what you would see from
Sudbury Road so Milford Road here so you
can see the access you can see where the
landscaping area would be on the open
space area with the sort of mature trees
retained this is within the site so this
is B P here you can see it's a range of
dwellings sort of similar to what else
we have in for modern developments in
the area it is outside of the
conservation area and the historic core
of latinum so it is considered that a
more modern type development is
acceptable and finally this is the this
street scene here so this these are the
houses and this is Sudbury Road and you
can see the TPO hedge retained and
enhanced along here ok so these are some
of the house types the thing to point
out here is the materials and how the
affordable and market dwellings it would
be ten year blind so they would have
similar materials so these are the
that's affordable homes and then these
are some of the market homes so you can
see that the same brick type and roof
material and we would want to condition
that to ensure that they were the same
again they have some different examples
of some vendor properties
this shows similar windows so plot of
seven would have similar window types to
the affordable dwellings and you'll note
here that these plots would have similar
door types so there are aspects of the
affordable dwellings repeated in the
market dwellings this is the bungalow so
it's going to be a single bungalow on
the site and then this is the landscape
master plan so you can see on here
the additional hedging and the trees
being protected with the landscape plan
again that's a similar plan with the
soft landscaping and this is the
external works plan so again you can see
the new roads and you can see the area
that would be potentially passed over to
the RP in that sort of lighter gray okay
so these just some photos of the site as
you can see it's just pretty much bearer
for at the moment with some scrubland
you can see the tree belt this is the
tree belt to the south and again this
provides this shows unit where the new
access would be so there would be
retention of of this hedgerow
it would be cut further down but
retention or landscaping on this
boundary as well so the recommendation
is as set out in your report page 50 and
51 with the additional comment at sorry
an additional comment of details of
materials thank you thank you very much
we have no parish cancel objector or
supporter but we have the applicant or
agent mr. Chris Smith you say I have
three minutes in which to address the
committee perhaps should remain seated
or standing at the end and I'll say this
any questions for you thank you
Thank You chairman members my name is
Chris Smith um development planner for
Hopkins Holmes and Hopkins are more as
you've heard following the grant of the
previous outline planning permission for
residential development on this site
we've developed and refined the detailed
proposals now before you in consultation
with your offices to produce the
development which we feel will be very
much in keeping with the character and
appearance of development within
Lavenham as you've noted the committee
report all the technical conservatives
are comfortable with the proposals that
are put forward as I said we feel in in
accordance with the officers that it
will produce an attractive new
development in a sustainable location as
you've heard delivering a much needed
new affordable homes together with the
requested financial contributions
previously indicated within the 106 and
volure Syl mechanism
I mean summary therefore we hope that
you can confer with your officers
recommendation that the proposals do
represent sustainable attractive
development and that you'll be able to
support the proposals thank you and I'm
happy to answer any questions anyone may
have thank you thank you very much
members have you any questions pencil
epatha followed by councillor plum thank
you mr. Smith I'm just conscious of the
comments of Lebanon Parish Council with
regards to the affordable housing which
I'm doubtedly you've read have you have
you had any conversations with laven and
parish council about about that I must
admit I haven't seen any very recent
comments we didn't meet with members of
the parish council before we submitted
the application we only had verbal
responses and indicated that they were
generally comfortable with what we were
proposing the scheme has evolved through
detailed discussions with offices since
that time but the I think the overall
principle of where the affordable
housing
posed on the site hasn't changed greatly
we did send copies of the plans to the
parish council before we submitted it to
follow in the meeting we didn't have any
direct response from them and the only
responses I've seen are the previous
ones they might see the application I
think speaking to officers we feel that
we've addressed that the comments in
terms of the detailed design as you've
heard the detailed design materials
finishes will be the same as the open
market house and as they are on all of
our developments and as you've heard in
terms of the location of the affordable
housing for both the benefit of the
thank you variable to the RCS further no
you haven't have you seen this the
comments of Evelyn parish councils which
are part of the tabled papers this
morning I haven't seen any very recent
ones I think that's we could give you a
copy please
and we'll come back to that okay after
you've had a chance to read a bit I
think members were just giving Charles
to read it's very short statement say
that
okay you've read that does that help you
around some yeah I don't see we've we've
mentioned about the affordable housing
yes that the the parish should referred
to this pet reporting approach I think
as you've heard on larger schemes
yes certainly affordable housing would
be spread in different clusters across
the site here you've heard we've only
got our site for 25 dwellings there's
only 80 affordable dwellings obviously I
just below the figure quoted for a
maximum cluster size by your officer so
I think we feel that given the
circumstances here as you've heard the
requirement to deliver these affordable
houses in one tranche at a certain point
in time within the development but for
obvious practical and commercial reasons
it makes sense to have them where they
are and as you've heard in terms of
future service delivery they'll be easy
to manage in one location for the
housing association concerns so I think
that that probably answers that point in
terms of the adjacent garage we have had
discussions with offices on that as
you've heard in terms of noise there was
a noise report done with the outline
application that indicated that the
noise came from the roads rather than
the garage itself and obviously we've
tried to provide a degree of separation
and orientate the dwellings to try and
maximize the distance from that that
boundary as far as possible thank you I
think the part of the question or
service any others for you Kancil aplomb
at you chair you're being asked by the
parish council to consider a Pepperpot
approach mainly because this for laven
is a relatively large development would
you be in any way come to meet them and
half way or are you saying that the
reasons for for putting there before
were housing in one position outweighs
every other benefit I think what we're
saying is that in given the size this
site impractical
there are benefits for all parties in
heaven the affordable housing where it's
proposed to be located in one group
whilst it clearly could be separated
into two groups it would make life
harder for this Housing Association
there'd be two separate areas for them
to look after there'd be two separate
areas for us to transfer and try and
build at the same time so obviously we
would have to build in between wherever
they were and obviously it would change
the layout it's a small site it's
constrained by tpo trees on one side
some materials on another a garage
that's still operation on the other side
which we need to to keep some distance
from and obviously we wanted British
something's attractive deliverable
complies with all the technical
requirements for highways etc so as I
say if there have been various
iterations of this layer and we've we've
got to where we've got to so whilst
there clearly could be sculpted to to
relocate some of the affordable houses
into another part of the site it would
have knock-on effects both in in
management terms in commercial terms and
it's something we would prefer to keep
the layout as it is and in terms of the
benefits of doing separating out on in
all honesty I can't see what they would
realistically be other than for
argument's sake some of the affordable
housing is splitting in one part of the
sort and summon another would say it's
gonna be ten you're blind it's all gonna
look the same so I'm not sure from the
the plank you know actually I think the
Obamas very factual you can try and keep
your answers a little bit more tighter
I know you've been put on the spot
because you hadn't seen those comments
I'm just gonna bring the chief officer
and I'll come back to you cancel upon
Thank You chair yeah in terms of a
policy justification for changing the
scheme as he is obviously officers feel
it's acceptable already strategic
housing has said 15 would be a property
of there altogether Lavenham does have
as members probably know h3 is an
affordable housing policy and all that
says was housing must be affordable
housing must be designed to be integral
to the development as a whole I don't
know if we can quickly look at the
drawing which to show
where it is in the layout but it's it's
all whilst it's in the same corner of
the site it's in three different bits if
you like and it's going to be ten you're
blind as well so one could argue that
it's integral to the site basically is
it's not - it's not a new from it's not
different - it's not all put in exactly
the same position I'd say there isn't a
strong policy reason to go away from the
layout that we've been given so I've got
there now yeah we have to click on the
just on that slide just to blow it out a
bit
I made a notice slurries 19 because I
was good asked a question as to where
they were actually Pinetree
so not really a strong policy
justification to change what we've been
given I think some members were sent
plans through the post from of the
applicant so they've got them in front
of the Newton see where they are much
clearer okay I cancel a plan
thank you so the answer to our question
is no and and if we reminded to refuse
on that basis
what would your plans but well clearly
as we said we prefer to keep it as is
obviously yes we Davis coped if you were
not happy with this then we'd after we
look at things and obviously we have
options of hopefully negotiating where
that officers or worst case would have
to put in another application but
clearly as we've said we feel that yeah
as the officers pointed this there's
effectively a corner where there are
before there's a terrace of three a pair
of Sammy's two pairs of Sammy's in the
detached property in one corner of the
site now we could move those around but
I'd to say I think that this benefits of
doing that would outweigh the benefits
so my desire as as the case officer is
indicated would be for the the proposals
to be approved in their current form
Thank You councillor maybe
Thank You mr. chairman and my question
is regarding the development along at
the Sudbury Road sorry along the supper
road and that it is big enough noted and
I'm hoping I can ask this question it's
been noted from the environmental house
about the noise
to those properties and I'm just asking
what you have thought about that in
regards to keeping - any suggestions
that you
make conditions of there should be
conditions about the noise impact on
those properties please
I know you've responded to that because
we have it in the paperwork but if you
can help counselor Mabry out on that
point from memory and offset and got it
in firmly I don't believe the noise
report indicated that any specific
measures were required above maybe
looking at the the thickness of glazing
in in certain windows if they're within
a certain distance of the road I think
the the noise report mainly indicated
that whilst there was a possibility or
an assumption that noise was emanating
from the garage that could be a problem
when actually the higher noise levels
were from traffic at peak hours along
the the roads and I think that there's a
lot of UT's the noisiest times along
that road will be in in morning and
evening Peaks rather than you know at
nighttime when the background noise
levels are low when people would be
sleeping which would be more of a
problem thank you I'm gonna bring in the
chief officer just to help out on that
because we found the page page 45
thank you you may have seen members at
the bottom of page 45 environmental
health and they've used the word
dominated by noise traffic I don't know
them in in terms of any noise going on
that was the dominant noise whether it
is a in itself a dominant noise it's
unclear but certainly they've they've
come up with solutions in terms of the
the closed border defense vs values and
at the top of page 46 it goes on
recommending what the you know what the
measures are that required basically so
they have not come up with an objection
but a set of measures to mitigate any
road noise thank you another question if
if I if I'm a chairman and if this is
not for this time then perhaps you will
advise me
my concern is these affordable houses
hopefully no it has to be a question is
the point the point is that over 300
people from the village are engaged in
the local businesses many of which are
working during the evening in
hospitality my concern is I do not have
other members may have a plan that
actually shows whether these houses
bordering on to Sudbury road will have
bedrooms with windows to the Sudbury
Road I think in fairness to penciler
Mabry the plan was sent to the existing
plan and members-only obviously you have
subbed for councillor Ayres one would
afford that she would have ordered that
plan and any other information she had
on to you but anyway we have seen sight
of the plan but can you pick up her
points which I've forgotten now I think
yes first of all some of the the
bedrooms will face towards that way in
those properties that front that way but
to say I think that the level of noise
that Skinner emanate he's gonna be from
from via Keeler traffic and the majority
of those movements
I accept there'll be some in the evening
but the majority will be doing morning
in peak hours when the background noise
levels around will be high so I don't
think if if the year indication is that
there's a need to rearrange the houses
just to for noise that might emanate in
in evenings to those bedrooms I don't
think that should be a major issue you
know sir I think if there was and always
issue it could be controlled by an
improved specification to the glazing
within those rooms
there are some inclined to agree view
effect that putting the houses back and
on to Main Roads are going to get no use
or either look enough that's sort of him
it's a fact of life isn't it but they
have taken necessary steps as the plan
offers pointed out to us any other
questions councillor parent thank you
just a question for you about the bin
storage because although most of the
properties probably have access to the
rear garden so they can store their bins
in babel with
most houses or many houses have at least
two bins the recycling and the red
and some have a golden refuse bin so
it's quite a storage problem some of
these units are middle Terrace what what
is their solution for bin storage sorry
only on the external works plan that the
officers have got there is an indication
of where the bin storage end
presentation areas are and as you
correctly said if it's a mid Terrace
than they will ever really gate that
enables them to to get the bin out of
the gate around the back and to the
front of the property so yes it's a
obviously a common thing we have to deal
with to comply by building regulations
and the requirements of waste collection
service then we have to provide being
collection and presentation points and
storage points and clearly yes we have
to make sure there was an external route
for those clearly we don't want the
dragon bins through after drag bins
through their houses in a modern house
to get it to the to the collection point
thank you
I've just got a question I'd like to ask
and this to do with the affordable
houses and in my area great cornered and
came to the plumbs area glimpse furred
as well as others we we have of these
estates usually allowed to amount of
Harris's and the 25 of your proposed and
and they put in affordable houses and
they tend to congregate them like you've
done in one area corner or what have you
and you did say in your statement at the
beginning that it's easier for
management and that's usually the
argument that I hear and when there's a
lot of affordable houses it tends to
make it ghetto there and I'm pleased to
note that in your your plans that you've
submitted that the materials good
equality is the ones for sale so that
they're not as easily identifiable as
being out of place or affordable or
anything else because people do need in
my opinion to be able to live in those
houses and not have that so obvious
putting them all together I feel does
tend to perhaps make the area more
obvious and splitting them up a bit more
might be an answer to not having them
all together
what's your comments on that I think as
I said on a larger site I would agree
and if we were proposing 200 houses then
yes they'd be three if not four clusters
of these in in in those smaller
groupings but he on those the smaller
glutton would still be probably have the
same or slightly larger size that we've
got in this location and as you said
they they tend you're blind the
materials would be the same as the
officers say it effectively they Rock
they're on if you like four different
plots within their area and as they all
look the same I think once once they
develop sin and lift in I don't think in
all honesty that you will notice that
there's any difference in those the
opposite of people that live in there
once they will get live in there they
will not be aware of whether they're
affordable or not and I think the case
in point where you know some of my
family live in affordable housing
there's groups larger than that on a
larger estate than in the three days
years that there have been there I've
not seen that there's been an issue from
anybody about those and everybody seems
to get on ok so I think it's in this
particular case that group and I think
ought to be acceptable and I think
there's enough space in between the
dwellings and materials that they
utilize that it will all look as as one
as one development as the the
neighbourhood plan policy requires thank
you who's next councillor I was born
father of our councillor Busby thank you
Thank You mr. chairman we're not just
two questions really first of all is
with the affordable housing have you
Housing Association in line or has
anybody come forward with that we
haven't got a Housing Association if you
like signed up yet
unfortunately housing associations until
such time as we have a piece of paper
that says planner permission we we
aren't in a position to do that what we
do do we have consultants that retain by
us that that will go around to to the
various register providers and see if
they're interested in bidding so we're
aware that there are housing
associations that will be willing to to
take these properties young one further
question was cheering on when you talk
about their management company for the
areas of green space has that has that
been identified or can you just clarify
the position with me as a management
company because obviously labor don't
take on the management of open space
areas anymore now on on and smaller
sites such as this there will be a
residence management company that is set
up by us to start with we retain a lot
of directorship on that for the first
five years so that we're on board to
help we have a managing agent who then
takes it on on our behalf each of the
residents which the property purchases
on completion of their purchase agree to
pay an annual sum into a pot effectively
towards that maintenance company to look
after the the landscaping in addition on
here which hasn't been raised yet is
because we are having to use permeable
paved roads which Suffolk County Council
highways won't adopt then the management
company will also be looking after that
road as well so well there's a there's a
clear reason - something we've done on a
number of these smaller sites where for
drainage purposes we have to use
permeable paving and permeable surfaces
to record with the requirements that the
local flood authority and maintaining
disposable surface water on the site and
at the same time looking after the open
spaces you said we're public bodies
unfortunately on that don't have the
resources to do that anymore
and the residents management company
we've found in the last certainly in my
12 years of dealing with it has been an
effective way and it works all the
residents pay their annual fee towards
it and they can then see the results and
there's our clear
in structure to make sure things get
done when they should do thank you
Cancellara Buzzbee thank you a couple of
comments thank personal thank you for
sending this it's very useful it would
have been even more useful if you have
completed the key so things on here that
have a bottom on it also it looks as
though the the green landscaping covers
half of the Sudbury Road on here so I
don't understand that it makes it look a
broader band of landscaping than he can
possibly be
secondly the it would have been better
to see more bungalows on there rather
than just the one I think we do know
there's a need if you look to the
housing me there's no whether you
completed a housing me but if you look
at the housing needs it is a bug
2-bedroom ugh those things like that for
old people to downsize in trying to get
to your question please yes I certainly
wheelchair not a wheelchair sorry will
chair the border the back with the
garage will you be putting up fences
along the bed about Gardens there's that
one that dotted line is what kind of I
will they be
yes I think this had been alluded to in
terms of the boundary with the garage
there will be fencing on hitch and put
there as shown on the drawings at the
moment it's just an open chain link
fence and clearly you know we need to
have a visual separation and both for
sound purposes revert and for visual
amenity purposes so there will be hard
things go along that boundary as well as
additional landscaping in terms of the
bungalow coming yes where if we go
people would say we like bungalows as
you'll appreciate bungalows are
land-hungry we're on a small site which
in commercial terms is quite tight vibe
in terms of viability terms we've
managed to get one bungalow on there it
would be difficult for us to achieve
anymore in commercial viability terms
that's why there's only one on there
again if it was a larger site we were
talking about 200 dwellings then yes we
might be able to have 10 15 20 bungalows
but on this connoisseur site that one is
really the most that we can thought
would be put on there thank you one is
better than down below to take your
party is it a trade-off
we demand 35% affordable housing which
you provided if we said lower depth of
25% would you therefore have more money
in the scheme to put in bungalows well
the since the simple answer is yes we
would have more money because as you
probably aware in terms of affordable
house and the money that we get from a
Housing Association just about pays for
the build cost so there's no if you want
profit in commercial profit in those so
yes if that was less than theoretically
we would have if you know a greater
degree of flexibility and providing you
know more coverage with bungalows and
less with two storeys Whelan's but
obviously we're dealing here with the
site that's got an outline plan a
permission with an agree section 106
agreement that stipulates how many
affordable houses they should be and the
you know the the requirement for those
in terms of they mix therefore that bit
is set and all we're looking at his
arranging a reasonable mix of properties
on the remainder of the site and
we've had negotiations with your offices
and said we know that there's always a
desire to provide more bungalows we
didn't have any to start with and we've
managed to change things around a little
bit to get one on but yes they ease
again we do they even thank you I'm
gonna get the officer to clarify a
couple of points that you're saving your
support Thank You chair a couple points
arose about noise issues just just to
clarify again the sub you rode aside it
was recommended be 1 point 8 meter close
for defense and also double glazing to
the bedroom to the facing outside
details of how that's garriage similar
glazing to rear bedroom of plots 1 2 3
and 13 to 16 so that those are all
detailed recommendations by
Environmental Control which will go into
proposed condition 2 at the end of your
report thank you do you guys come back
now just taking plot 17 in particular
which prabhakar secrets it's the one
right in the top right-hand corner the
north east its garden he's gonna get
there's going to be almost no Sun in
that bed garden at all it's very narrow
it's very close to the 1071 just wonder
whether that block of three if you could
move that further west and put the
Garrett the car parking spaces the other
side of that block of three you would
then a take the buildings away from the
road and provide a bit of Sun in that
back garden
that's redrawn the plan counselor
Buzzbee oh yes and you know what I have
to say to you have to deal with what's
in front of you I do take your part but
yeah if you wish to answer that you can
you don't have to I think that the
trouble with the sort of this size is
there's always things that you look at
and you can do you could change this you
could change that and so I think we've
got to a point where we'd say this is
what we'd like members to consider at
this point of time thank you
remembers any other questions no thank
you very much thank you for you know
it's a long time you sitting there have
to answer questions but hopefully it
will be helpful to us
no thank you
right that's the best thing came to
councillor the ward members is
councillor our fee counselor maybe
remember the plan committee cancel our
fee hasn't made any comments so members
has over to you counselor maybe did you
want to start yes thank you me thank you
mr. chairman this does give me great
cause for concern I wasn't the ward
member when they sent like planning
permission was was achieved however I
have serious concern hence that I was
asking about noise pollution for the
submarine Road as I was trying to
comment the village actually employs
three hundred people from the village
within the village communities and a lot
of it is hospitality and they work
nights so they will be wishing to sleep
during the day so I am very unhappy at
any bedroom windows being open or being
open on to the submarine Road whatsoever
I also concur with with my colleague
here councillor Busby about
at Number 17 that will be a very dark
corner which is a bit of a worry I also
have concerns about any pollution and I
know we've had a report from the garage
site they do actually state that they
work seven days a week
there is also light pollution because if
you look at it it's basically going into
a triangle although it's not quite
because the garage is there and I have a
serious concerns about how all of this
is actually laid out I'm pleased to hear
that there will be fencing which is
similar to acoustic to some of the some
of the areas I also definitely agree
about bungalows would be would have been
preferential in lots of these areas
because of the actual residential makeup
of the village so I'm going to leave it
at that and I shall listen to what my
other my other colleagues have I'm
really unhappy about the housing along
the Sudbury road with bedroom windows
opening onto it thank you well I think
those points have been highlighted and
commented on but garish pollution and
bulk pollution I think they're perhaps
relevant points but I think I would say
to you is that in wherever you create a
new smaller state or a larger state you
are going to have garages and you're
going to have street lights on because
these are what people want but our self
is you've got any comments on those
points you can help out the garage
pollution and the light pollution no I
mean the principle of development has
been accepted on this site and that took
into account at the outline stage the
fact that it was next to potentially
noisy neighbor they did the work that
they were required to do in terms of the
noise assessment that showed that the
noise was from the roads rather than the
garage and therefore we have accepted 25
dwellings on this site and that given
the constraints within it that does mean
that there are going to have to be
dwellings you know backing on to both
Sudbury road and on to the garage
because realistically in order to retain
those trees you can't have development
on the south side which might be the
quieter side thank you
any other comments members
penciler Barrett just like to say really
I think it's acceptable in terms of
layout design landscape and suggests
that it is the norm to have double
glazing throughout the house and it
would be any new houses built without
that and so that that would deal with
the the road noise that might arise and
actually the road I think is 40 mile
hour at that stage of the supper erode
so cars should not be speeding so I
think although there was you know
obviously and some noise I think it
wouldn't be detrimental and I I would
like to suggest approval thank you
do I have a seconder my counselor Parker
do wish to comment at this day well only
just to say that I concur with
councillor Barrett's comments chair I
I'm respectful and mindful of the
comments of Lavin and parish council but
you know a lot of it is subjective isn't
it Jen and actually I think is quite an
attractive development I'll be honest
and and I think given the constraints
that the the site is faced with I think
that actually the developers done quite
a nice job here but I take on board the
comments at the parish council that you
know maybe it doesn't fit the leaven and
vernacular but if if the representation
if the representation is anything to go
by there's somebody who lives two
villages of wine has lived here all my
life I would suggest that actually it
does with respect to council and ivory
I'm looking at the plan here and looking
across the sub B Road and looking at
Google Maps then actually that as far as
I can tell there aren't any windows that
look directly into anything across that
B Road so all things concern or all
things considered chair I think I think
it's a good little development actually
and I would willingly support it yeah
thank you on that
just before the vote churches reminder
the additional condition 3 if that could
be gone through you yeah well I'm sure
though the additional condition but I'll
come to that condition 3 you addicts
except that counselor it is the
materials being tenure blind basically
so we'll have to agree them to us if
that just like to say at this stage
Lebanon is medieval fill easily it is
attractive it it's nicely set out and I
think in fairness to Lebanon and the
parish council they've taken on board
quite a lot of housing for us and also
some quite affordable houses and I would
have been more concerned I think if this
wasn't an attractive site and I think in
fairness to the applicant they they have
tried and they've listened to our
concerns because this Planning Committee
over the last year or two has come down
quite heavy on the fact that we'd like
more bungalows we'd like larger rooms in
the dwellings that they build not send
little box rooms and that we would want
the affordable to look attractive and
not look cheap and nasty and I think in
fairness they don't I think the next
stage that they need to perhaps take on
board is not having them all pushed
together but I think I have to accept it
is a small site of only 25 even perhaps
in that one corner but I don't think
they should be there necessarily because
it's easier to maintain
I think you know if they've dotted about
a bit they could still be maintained but
we have got to deal with what's in front
of his members so I would remind you on
that
no cancel Osborne table by cancel plan
thank you Miss Jimmy just actually for
our room opposite president I'm sorry
just for our officer president Billy can
I just just have a clarification please
of the conditions that I know this
perhaps too and the other one is can you
can you just clarify the withdrawal of
PD rights please what they're involved
on this site please yeah yeah I had to
discuss them the original case officer
about this I mean you would normally do
that at outline but he said looking at
what's in front of him it was clear that
that was desirable basically so just to
sort of thing doesn't go over develop
with bits and pieces of extensions no
just to say that the reason why there
are so few comment conditions is the
majority of those has been put on the
outline so that's about 30 yeah 30
conditions on the outline so it's only
additional things so it would be the
noise attenuation the PD rights and the
details of materials so that just
applies to conservatories and stuff like
that yeah we would probably look at
removing extensions so that they would
need permitted development for
extensions we can look at other things
that would probably be the main one
possibly outbuildings but we would allow
things like window lights and so on
Thanks Thank You Chancellor plan Thank
You chair and I'm sorry but I can't
accept the clustering of the affordable
housing my own bitter experience in my
own ward it doesn't matter how big the
site is how many houses there are you
will get arise that particular area and
as parish council would like to see it
that approach and even if it's this
isn't
diction or not in contravention of
Lebanon neighborhood plan in fact it is
in terms of what they would like so I
can't support this application I'm
serving teacher and answer that h3 which
you looked at earlier at which I quoted
basically which refers to as the council
suggesting thank you I never comments no
right members then it's a slow over
comments has been proposed by Chancellor
Barrett and seconded by Councillor
partial that we accept the officers
recommendation that's laid out in sundry
klett plus the extra condition little
three wasn't it that we saw some more
yep
all those in favor please show those
against to that is carried thank you
that is approved members it's four
minutes past eleven and I can see
councillor Busby would like to come for
break so we will have a comfort break
until then fifteen
you
welcome back members will continue with
our on page 55 and it is the the first
wonderful Road suffering a case officer
is Rose Walton we also have and who may
be speaking or you may want to question
have a Tucker Corporation manager of
housing solutions and if you just wave
they move yes laid in the strategies
dress thank you right rose overview
Thank You chair this application is for
a change of use to homeless persons
accommodation of comprising of eight
beds it's and has been called to
committee as Bay the District Council
are the applicant the site is located
within the build up area boundary of
North Sudbury along the northern side of
Walden Field Road
these are the main baby local plan and
core strategy policies that relate to
the application the the vapor and mid
Suffolk homes and housing strategy
states that homelessness should be
prevented ensuring that everyone has a
suitable home where residents are able
to live as healthily safely and
independently as possible within
sustainable communities the Baber core
strategy also observes that different
groups of people and individual
communities have particular demands and
often urgent needs for different
accommodation a key thrust of the core
strategy reflecting the overarching
social dimension of the MPP F is to
provide homes for all the provision of
eight bed sets for homeless persons in
an established residential area with
local amenities and services accessible
by foot and public transport represents
a significant benefit consistent with
local and national housing policies this
is the site as you can see it is
detached property with existing access
and parking and a rear garden situated
when the within a built up largely
residential area there are no
constraints to the site with no listed
built buildings in the near vicinity and
it's not in a conservation area or
special landscape area 13 neighboring
properties were consulted and they are
highlighted on this story and we
received no objections
we received no objections from any
console tease the Suffolk County Council
highways have recommended a condition
for the provision of cycle storage to
promote sustainable travel alternatives
this is an aerial view of the site as
you can see the surrounding area is
largely residential with a few shops and
takeaway restaurants as well as good
access to public transport here is
another reminder of the site plan here
are the ground floor plans as they are
existing and proposed with five bed sets
and a shared kitchen laundry room toilet
and bathroom as highlighted here are the
first four floor plans as they are
existing and proposed having three bed
sets and a shared bathroom as
highlighted there these are the front
elevation plans as they are existing and
proposed one door would be replaced with
a window and one ground-floor window
would be enlarged there would be no
extensions and all external finishes
would remain as existing these are the
rear elevation plans as they are
existing and proposed all ground-floor
doors and windows would be replaced with
three windows
the side elevations would remain as
existing the character of the
surrounding development is a mix of
two-story and single storey properties
and set back from the road with a mix of
finishes of red brick and render this is
the site
these are bungalows these are a row of
flat roof garages
these are two-story dwellings as are
these and there are also more flat roof
garages to the rear and a parking area
in terms of resident to amenity there
would be limited potential for
overlooking as the first floor windows
are to remain as existing there is also
limited potential for light looking as
no extensions to the property are
proposed and the boundary treatments
would remain as existing the enclosed
area marked here is the rear garden of
the property which has no interval 'ti
the east facing flank wall of the
neighboring two-story dwelling which is
highlighted in blue and has no
first-floor windows that overlook this
area this is the view of the property
from the garages to the rear this is the
property and this is that east facing
elevation of the neighboring two-story
dwelling as you can see there are no
first floor overlooking windows the
access is already existing and two
offered spaces are provided the Suffolk
County Council highways authority have
raised no objections to this this site
is sustainable in transport terms having
good access to
public transport and services and
amenities within walking distance
although the site offers two or three
parking spaces welding field Road and
the surrounding roads don't have parking
restrictions and are wide enough to
accommodate on street parking if
required
currently welding field Road is used for
on street parking for some local
residents and visitors however many
dwellings along this road have off
burrowed parking provision in addition
to this given the nature of the persons
who will occupy the beds it's further
on-site parking is not required the
condition recommended by Suffolk County
Council highways will assist in the
promotion of sustainable travel
alternatives the recommendation is for
approval of FQ thank you very much Rose
for that very high-tech presentation
that was excellent I could follow all
those colors quite easily
they're very good of us garden fest
right at just one point I want to
clarify could the two plan offers that
tell us Yushu eight properties I think
it was where you'd consulted the
neighbors what do you actually send out
to these neighbors what do they get just
that we were proposed to travel to a
dwelling or what can you just explain
that the the letter they will have
received in common with the site notice
else just outside the property we'll
have a description as you see in front
of you so it will tell them there was a
planning application for change of use
as you can see there bla bla
homeless persons unit with 8-bit sets so
they'll get that letter to them that's
what proposal is thank you very much
that's quite clear right we have no
public speakers for Town Council
objectors supporter applicant or agent
which is also spose county councillor
but councillor Alison Owen is a member
of the Planning Committee in such that
you've decided to stay and remain as
part of the plan
so that you can take part in it as often
as you wish right then I'll come
straight to you to open the debate thank
you very much yep it's last one yeah
Thank You mr. chairman
no I just I had something - we have -
two
officers from hoverson and housing I do
part of it could we have their comments
on exactly the position of those before
we actually go to debate with that
pencil oh and as I had called you he
wants the two officers to get a comment
before we go into debate you're happy
you're okay thank you very much so that
counts lower right I'll come to you
officers and between you perhaps should
take us through what you want to tell us
what you need
good morning counselors and the reason
we chose to propose the conversion of
d'affaires is because we desperately
require more temporary accommodation
within our districts and at the moment
we unfortunately often have to place
homeless individuals into
bed-and-breakfast accommodation in
Ipswich which was naturally outside of
our district we want to try and place
people within our within our ward
boundaries not to keep them close to
their employment family and support
networks and for those with children
close to their schooling naturally if we
play some that the district this can
create quite a lot of complexities for
them with sustaining those links as of
today we actually have 12 individuals
accommodated in bed-and-breakfast
outside of the district by providing
extra eight units within the district
that would significantly reduce that it
would also help us work towards the
ambitions out in the homelessness
production and mass sleeping strategy
which was approved by members earlier in
the year which aims to eradicate the use
of bed-and-breakfast longer term and
we're very much focused on trying to
keep people within our district and
having more suitable accommodation or
although this is still shared
accommodation its accommodation that we
will manage and we will it will be more
suitable than placing bed-and-breakfast
where at the moment we're not the only
people to place in bed-and-breakfast
other local authorities place in there
as well so though they the individual
bed and breakfast providers do risk
assess and assess you know who would be
most appropriate to place we will know
exactly who we're placing it would only
be people that we place in there so we
feel that by providing more
accommodations in our districts that is
in our management this would be far
better for our residents okay so would
this be solely for homeless people or if
you had empty rooms or spaces and you
had an other category of people not got
a roof over their head would you comment
in there for a short time and the
accommodation would only be for those
that we would owe a duty to under
homelessness and if we ever got to a
position where we didn't need all of
those rooms and we'd do a review of our
stock and look at actually whether we've
got too many temple accommodation
unit unfortunately away things are at
the moment I can only see increasing
tempo accommodation further I can't see
us reducing that at the moment we do
work because of the way we work with me
Suffolk we do place within each other's
districts if we need to so at the moment
we have got a couple of paper applicants
actually placed into me to suffer the
temporary accommodation rather than
leaving there's empty so we do try and
use the fact that we are working
together as both councils and make best
use of stock across both rather than
placing into bed and breakfast may
chairman it's just to confirm it's not
intended anybody would have a long-term
secure housing act tendency of because
it would be bit difficult because
they're sharing facilities in any case
they would be exempt because they're
temporary I'm under forget which part of
schedule one it is but they have their
housing out there being provided for
temporarily so by definition not secure
tenants is that right thank you
yeah the accommodation we provides
leaving under Section 108 or section one
line three so it's a temporary
accommodation duty these have actually
last sensible rooms so all of our
temporary accommodation is licensed
which is sort of the lease security of
tenure somebody can have but with a view
that they move on to more security Nia
it's an it's a transitional
accommodation it's somewhere somebody
can stay until grow to find a more
permanent solution whether that be and
either to private rented or social
rented sector thank you
members because we've got the house and
solution manager and team here I think
if it's okay review if you wish to ask
questions during the debate directed to
them there then we'll feel that question
okay so we'll take the debate as normal
and if there's a question for them
rather than the planning officers here
we'll expect you to come in with some
help out thank you
right members councillor oh and you're
really and this really nice to see that
homelessness and everything is gonna be
accommodated in Sudbury just want to ask
how long is temporary when you say it's
gonna be a temporary competent
commendation
how long will that be thanks for your
question counselor I mean and if there's
no set Pacific time it depends on what
duty somebody's under and what options
we have I mean on average at the moment
the stay varies between often sources
three and nine months it's sometimes can
be longer that does generally tend to be
for the larger families where we have
less stock and these would generally be
for single people so on average probably
around six months but it could easily be
less or sometimes slightly more
depending on what their needs are but
but it wouldn't ordinarily be more than
a sort of nine months or so yeah no
sorry
any other comments members councillor
Busby yeah a couple points that to pick
up you mentioned schooling would be
putting children into these rooms we
have on occasions we do have to use
shared accommodation we try and move
them into self-contained but if the
option was we had maybe for a family
there was two rooms available in example
affairs or it was a case of placing in
bed and breakfast out of the district I
would much rather we place them in our
own stock where they're close to
schooling with a view to moving them to
more suitable self-contained
accommodation when one becomes available
we review our temple accommodation every
day literally every day sometimes more
than once a day because things do change
so frequently and it's about having that
balance and you know we try and keep
people as close to the networks and
schooling and employment over and above
you know if it means place them out of
the district are you saying that we have
quite a few homeless people with young
children yeah the majority of our
homeless applicants are families with
children so we place them into
accommodation we have far fewer single
homeless people but we do get single
homes people as well we also get single
and and/or couples with that might be
pregnant so may not have had the
children yet that may need accommodation
but we do have a large number of
families that we're supporting with
fighting long-term housing if I might
and you mentioned manage how you manage
to do that understand the physical
administration of the rooms but what
other services do you provide we have
two full-time staff that are based out
in the district's managing our temple
accommodation units in Baber we have 36
units at the moment and this obviously
if we have approval for this what it
takes up to 44 they also manage the
units in mid suffix districts as well
but they're out on the districts all day
every day going out talking to residents
we do regular room inspections
normally fortnightly we deal with any
issues any matters that arise where you
know residents might be in dispute about
noise or or suchlike so we do have
staffing on-site we also have a support
workers that are not solely focused on
temporary commendation but we have three
based in the house and solutions team
and they will offer to support to those
that are actually in temporary
accommodation require support to help
them with maintaining their tenancy and
reduce the risk of homelessness
reoccurring because unfortunately even
though we provide accommodation doesn't
necessarily mean someone can sustain it
without some support to try and prevent
them from returning to actually being
street homeless so you don't actually
they're responsible for cleaning the
normal day to day stuff they are
responsible for keeping their own room
tidy and clean and we expect people to
tidy up after themselves they use
communal kitchens and bathrooms we do
have contract cleaners come in and clean
communal areas once or twice a week
depending on the side of the size of the
scheme but we are we do try and
encourage listeners to take ownership
and responsibility because obviously
when they move on from there they're not
going to have people coming in doing
their cleaning for them and so if the
properties aren't being well maintained
they do get warning letters advice and
then we expect them to clean up after
themselves when they've been in the
kitchens bathrooms and they sort
communal spaces thank you so what you're
saying then really we're going back to
what we used to have in Sudbury at the
top near the fire station there which
was the old NASA's at home and which is
taking a third into unit that was babies
homeless
which I remember many many years ago I
was part of help and get that all set up
so it's a complete circle we're going
back south sorry it's greatest when this
first read it sounded like it wasn't
family she were including but I know
your sound that it's yes yes I've gotta
cancel maybe next baby
Thank You mr. chairman I didn't being to
cutting short but generally speaking
this will be for single individuals but
what I wouldn't want is if we've got you
know an empty room which is suitable for
a family
I wouldn't want us to exclude them from
being placed within our districts and
placing them out districts in regards to
and the property or talking about
absolutely means tower house which was
converted in number of years ago into
eleven self-contained flats that is
where we try and prioritize families so
they have self-contained accommodation
these are these are big flats that will
in a place which is what it's now known
as an over house or the subsequently
built handling house next door which
provides another four units of
self-contained accommodation and we will
try and prioritize families for
self-contained accommodation wherever we
can but all I'm saying is you know if if
we've got faith concedes within
somewhere like this or other shared
accommodation I would much rather we
placing within our districts then move
them into a bed-and-breakfast outside of
the district it's about making that is
absolutely booze it to my ears because I
always felt we should never have closed
that down and altered it we should have
stuck with it and carried on but anyway
we're back there now so members
counselor maybe Thank You mr. chairman
and I've really approve of housing for
homeless that's the worst thing ever
must be for someone to to be homeless I
am concerned about shared facilities in
these in these days particularly when
you're talking about families possibly
being there with children and I have
experience of this too it would
be I'm just trying to get my head around
this if you have identified that the
majority of the need is for families why
this has this building or proposal has
not been split in another way
ie perhaps the top floor is a separate
unit for a family and downstairs as
other because if you're trying to put a
family in one room and I know you
haven't said that yet surely there isn't
the room for a parents and two children
in one room and if there even if they're
side-by-side with shared facilities I'm
sure that parents would be quite
concerned about what is going on in
Kensal of Avery you're quite right and I
share a lot of what you're saying I'm
sure members do I have to remind you we
have to deal with what's in front of us
I'm not sure that's strictly the
planning side of it but I will get the
answers on it because I think it is
important that members I know we all can
strain on this subject if we can try and
keep it to the planning side but perhaps
you can help us out because counsel
maybe we've got very valid points about
share and facilities I don't like that
we all have on Suites nowadays
historically we would have very few
single people we do have more now than
we have historically that's largely due
to a change in case law that came about
where there was a case that went to the
High Court where they looked at
vulnerability for single people and as a
result we do more single people at duty
now than we did previously
however the lion's share of our work
still is homeless families where we have
to provide accommodation and what I
wanted to make sure is that where we
have two self-contained accommodation
were able to prioritize the families for
that the single individuals will then
share of accommodation in somewhere like
Affairs at the moment when we place in
bed and breakfast out of the districts
they do share facilities so you know we
are placing people out the districts in
shared facilities at the moment I feel
it better to place people within our
districts separately for this planning
matter there is a strategic review of
temple accommodation being done over the
next few months and there will be
papers go into cabinets next year to
look at potentially providing more
temporary commendation longer-term but
that isn't a selling issue for today but
I just feel that does hopefully answer
your question around what you know what
temporal combination do we need and
what's most suitable there is a longer
term plan for looking at what
accommodation we need but we feel this
is a good option for fishing for
predominantly single single people thank
you or the two classes just once I just
want to remind members I'm not sure this
was in the report obviously Rose had
inherited quite late so thank you for
presenting but it should be made clear
that were this for six people it
wouldn't need planning permission you'll
be a c4 use class which you're allowed
to change to from a c3 dwelling house so
actually the extent of what needs
permission is just two rooms two people
so that's the soft spaceman from the
Nuvi we've got here in our consideration
I would suggest for that would be six
people so so it's a little bit beyond
what doesn't need planning permission
that's all I want to say at churches to
remind members they also I was I was
going to speak I'm glad I didn't because
I think Heather's answers confirmed what
I suspected I used to specialize in
housing or it was a long time ago and
I'm out of date so I do recall it's
still the case isn't it people come to
us and we have to assess what used to be
called priority need or vulnerability
and that meant and that used to be when
I did it all those years ago that meant
either responsibility for young children
or age or physical or mental health now
I mean you know I think you know the
case law best in me it's now slightly
more generous
that's right obviously yet so but I mean
and we still we have a duty to advise
and assist as at section 96 still which
would so if somebody was able-bodied and
young they'd probably get they get some
help in finding accommodation that it
might be available yet yeah so an
introduction of the homelessness
reduction act we have more advice and
assistance duties now than we had
historically where it used to be a
discretionary power
it's an hour statute of duty
the priority needless relation is still
there and we still got the kind of
guidance the fact that up and it's just
where we've had case law which has made
it means that we now have a duty to more
individuals and we did previously but
yes it's basically those are deemed of
duty under priority need legislation or
case of thank you
councillor Busby could you go to slide
10 why are you digging that out at G I'd
like to propose that we have a post site
visit I want it's been converted I'd
actually like to see the unit to see
what it's like even if it's occupied
in fact preferably if it's occupied just
to find out a bit more about how people
use it and how comfortable you are with
this I see no reason why we can't ask
the cabinet members that are responsible
to arrange a meeting for us and yes I'm
one have to do that to be honest what we
will do and what we did when we opened
another property in in mid Suffolk
previously which actually held an open
morning so also for local residents
because sometimes people can sort of you
know that connotation they think home
Assessor think there's going to be
problems we've actually actually
realized and potentially you know anyone
could potentially become homeless at any
time merely and so we'll hold an open
morning where we will invite people to
come along and have a look in the local
neighborhood alright so the mall itself
to the more than welcome to come will
also be inviting the ward member cabinet
members and cabinet laid for housing
leaders to come out and have a look and
also offices to come out and see what
we've done and to see so when they're
talking to individuals they can talk
some about what the temple accommodation
consists of thank you I can just I
wasn't a party he says he was suggesting
okay so can you just talk me through I
can't quite read some other things
you've got legal what's the bottom left
is that say laundry okay so at the
bottom left in the yellow so as you go
through the door to the left-hand side
it's a laundry so they'll be washing
machines and tumble dryers for them to
do their laundry right then I think it's
a store in front of that I can't leave
it on here I think the next one is a
store then to the right it's a large
kitchen and there'll be sufficient
cookers and sinks in there for the
number of people staying so we have
regulations you have to follow under the
Housing Act about the number of kitchen
facilities per person so there will be
two ovens two sinks they'll be
sufficient washing machines and tumble
dryers that's where I think they'll have
to be two of each with in the laundry
then round pass the stairs to right hand
side will be a communal bathroom which
will have a bath and a separate shower
and then there's obviously the five
bedrooms and then upstairs
I understood the upstairs there's no
actual lounge communal land no no
there's no common or lounge they will
have they'll just have their own rooms
we've previously had two schemes where
we have shared facilities and we have
communal lounges and we've a find
they're not used or they're not used
appropriately and actually residents
prefer to spend time in their own space
so we've actually chosen not to have any
communal land so we'll just have their
own rooms and share the kitchen bathroom
and laundry spaces somebody would like
to see upstairs so if you could go to
the next slide and the other question I
had was worth two questions the rear
garden was quite a big garden who looked
after that and what what facilities are
in that and the gardens mainly laid two
lawn with shrubs around the outside and
that's maintained by our in-house public
realm team they maintained at the moment
and they will maintain it if the
conversion is approved they have access
to
it would be shared and it will be
maintained by the public realm team and
whilst I'm on the microphone on the top
floor so you've got the extra three
bedrooms and then the other bathroom
we're retaining so that will provide
another bath toilet and a separate
shower so they're a two bathrooms one
large kitchen but in effect it's almost
like two kitchens and then the large
laundry space as well and then my final
port point was really about the parking
I know highway said they're happy with
it but you've got if their family is
going to be in there's only two parking
spaces we talked about them being able
to park outside on the road
I don't know that area is that the last
frontage I believe isn't it generally
speaking like I say it will be single
people play status and it won't be an
everyday occurrence or placing families
that will generally be singles from the
at the moment the number of single
people we place actually have their own
transport is minimal and we don't have
we have other sites where we have very
minimal parking it's like some site so
we have zero parking and we don't have
parking issues there so we're not
foreseeing this being an issue but
office it's something it will monitor
and we'll address if there's a problem
look at the Gary bees they were to the
left of it do we own do we own those are
they are they used they are used trying
to find a picture of the front because I
think it says show you know although
they're spaces there I reckon you could
squeeze two or three cars in there quite
easily any other questions
Oh cancel it may very sorry Thank You
mr. Chanin and I don't know the answer
so please if you could tell me what is
the requisite number of laboratories
needed for eight basic bits it's please
we it's one per five individuals that's
what we've got to so there's 100 grand
for one on the first floor in the
designs that's why we've got to because
that would meet the Housing Act
regulations so all of these plans have
been approved by the private sector
housing to
they're the ones that go out and license
houses and Multiple Occupation so
because we're a local authority and it's
our property we don't actually license
our own but we make sure our properties
are to the same standards those if it
was a private person coming to us
wanting to license the property so it
will meet all the regulations I set out
within the Hat you know hang some
Multiple Occupation legislation so we're
as open and transparent as we would
expect a private applicant in
legislation came in around licensing
last October we had we asked for
Christ's sector housing to come in and
inspect all of our temple accommodation
where its shared accommodation so even
though we don't have to license it
ourselves
we wanted to make sure that we're doing
the same standards that we'd expect
other people have in our districts to do
I killed counselor maybe if I made I
just find that surprisingly few for for
the map for the amount particularly if
you're going to have children
perhaps sharing a room with parents I
just find that quite a low amount but
that's my opinion
thank you any other comment consider
Barrett one comment then and your
question that I should say um what are
the regulations about fire then that
sort of springs to mind with multiple
multiple Kuban see in terms of alarms
and fire doors and yes so the property
has been assessed owned by surveyors and
compliance individuals have been out and
herded officers have been out and had a
look and they've designed what fire
protection systems we need so in the
businessperson we have looked at doing
the conversion we've got it all proposed
about exactly which regulations we need
to meet what type of fire alarm system
it is what type of fire does we need the
number of fire exits all of that is is
built in so all of that would be set up
it will be have an alarm system built in
and normally the fire service will come
out and have a look in those sorts of
circumstances before we we open it up
and and see
how'd he make any recommendations much
asabi our residents allowed to smoke in
the public areas or is it classed as a
smoking is only permitted outside of the
dwelling
they can't smoke indoors and that's the
same with all of our Tempe accommodation
is shared how long is this going to take
to completion to open and the proposal
initially was April but and because of
the time it's having to go through
applying for the planning consent we're
now expecting it hopefully to be June
any other questions members no Castle
apparent perhaps I can propose that we
accept then everyone is asked questions
and satisfies themselves so I can get a
second to fall you can't slow us but I
think you've actually said unless
there's anything new anybody wants to
bring up no well it's been proposed and
seconded that we follow the officers
recommendation as laid off from the
papers before you all those in favor
please show that's unanimous
anyone against I thank you very much
that is carried but I think members
we've got to the aims of our baton and
just to point out that there isn't site
inspection the date of our next meeting
is the faux fur December and the one
after that is the 18th of December I
believe and I'm led to believe that both
of them at this moment will be on and
one could have more applications than
the other one so bear in mind that if
that alters I will get the officers to
let you know by email as soon as
possible so that you have more time to
go and do your Christmas shopping
I'll think about that one and let you
know in due course councillor Busby case
law school yes sorry miss Jenna can you
just repeat then take some elves
daydreaming thought I got on Wednesday
for December 9:30 and Wednesday the 18th
of December 9:30 although there's a
possibility that that Taemin could be
altered now I think mid suffix also got
a meeting so we may have to work in with
them thank you can I can I just dim say
thank you to our plane officer you